la crise se poursuit à ottawa les
résidents se pose une question
que fait la police d'ottawa le ministre
de la sécurité publique se pose
maintenant la même question
explique mme à l'inaction de la police
d'ottawa il faut dire que les
manifestants sont bien enracinées ce qui
limite les possibilités d'intervention
explique cet ancien policier qui a
repris des proportions importantes et
charlotte définitivement complet
les policiers d'ottawa 10 d'avoir un
plan pour sortir de la crise mais manque
d'effectif pour l'exécuter l'ancien chef
de police croit pour sa part qu'un
changement d'approché s'impose leur
stratégie ne semble pas avoir un impact
positif sur la réduction
du nombre de manifestants
devant l'impasse le gouvernement trudeau
considère le recours à la loi sur les
mesures d'urgence une loi temporaire qui
peut être adoptée en situation de crise
nationale et qui permet à ottawa de
gouverner par décrets et donc d'agir
plus vite c'est certainement un outil
qui existe et qui pourrait produire un
effet de l'ultimatum
décroché
en ontario le premier ministre d'oxford
a déjà déclaré l'état d'urgence mais
cette mesure exceptionnelle n'a pas
dissuadé le noyau dur de manifestants
signe que la sortie de crise ne sera pas
nécessairement juridique sabres 1 du
droit mais son amende peut
s'apprendre volonté politique de le
faire respecter on doit être prêt pour
toute éventualité justin trudeau a déjà
affirmé que toutes les options étaient
sur la table pour mettre fin au blocage
le premier ministre a convoqué un groupe
d'intervention ce week end mais ne s'est
pas exprimé à nouveau sur la crise qui
secoue le pays si à ce média radio
canada montréal